There’s this scene in the movie Arrival
where Jeremy Renner’s character, who's a scientist,
is brought in to try to help the military
deal with alien spaceships that have landed
across the globe.
And in an early version of the script, he asks
if the aliens have responded to Fourier series
sent out by the humans.
Problem is, that wasn’t really the right
math reference.
“Well, a Fourier series is a mathematical
concept, but it's not, like, a series of numbers
so I, I changed that to Fibonacci series — which
is in fact a series of numbers that aliens
might actually send us as a way of getting
our attention.”
Phil is an astronomer and science blogger,
and he’s also part of the Science and Entertainment
Exchange, an organization that connects creators
in Hollywood with scientist script advisors.
They set up a phone number for screenwriters
like Arrival’s Eric Heisserer, who want
their scientific references to sound right.
“Here’s one of the things I wanted to
make sure to do with this movie — and that’s
not to be embarrassed about complicated ideas,
not to be embarrassed or ashamed of hard
science.
That these are the words and the terms that
people in this position would be sharing
with each other.”
Phil’s advice to use “fibonacci” added
that extra bit of credibility.
“And a I didn't really think much of that
but then you know, I go see the movie, and
Jeremy Renner actually says that….
“Have they responded to anything — shapes,
patterns, numbers, Fibonacci?”
“… and I'm nudging my wife like, pointing,
pointing to the screen, pointing, like yeah,
he said what I wrote, that's so cool!”
There’s a lot of really bad science in TV
and movies.
“I’m getting hacked!”
There’s bad computer science, bad geology,
bad physics.
So in 2008, the Office of Communications at
the National Academy of Sciences launched
the Science and Entertainment Exchange.
Here’s how it works: you call the number,
you describe your question, and then the team
filters through their database of 2,400 scientists
and engineers to put you in touch with the
right person.
They estimate that they’ve done between
1700 and 1800 consultations since they started.
That includes almost every Marvel movie, and
two 2017 Oscar nominees.
A lot of times, the consultation boils down
to changing a line to include a scientific
concept.
In early discussions for the 2011 Thor movie,
producer Kevin Feige needed a way to represent
the “rainbow bridge” that reaches between
Earth and the realm of the Gods in Norse mythology.
So he met with Sean Carroll, a physics professor,
who later paraphrased their conversation in
a blog post.
Carroll suggested they describe the bridge
as wormhole.
Feige didn’t want to do that, because it
sounded too Nineties.
MERCHANT: And he said, “Well, there is this
thing called the Einstein-Rosen bridge.”
“Einstein-Rosen bridge?
What is that?”
Einstein-Rosen Bridge is the technical name
for a wormhole.
And they said “We LOVE Einstein-Rosen bridge.”
Listen to the dialogue in the movie, and you
can hear where they added in the concept of
an Einstein-Rosen Bridge.
"An Einstein-Rosen Bridge is a theoretical connection between two different points of space-time."
"It's a wormhole."
But the team’s focus isn’t just about
what characters are saying — it’s also
about who is saying them.
In the original Thor comics, Natalie Portman’s
character — Jane Foster — is a nurse.
The physics professor who consulted the filmmakers
argued that it would make more sense for
the plot if she was a physicist studying the
wormhole that brought Thor to Earth.
And for the Exchange, that sounded like the
perfect opportunity to break down gender stereotypes.
“We love nurses, but we also really love
the idea of a strong female character who
was an astrophysicist.”
So the writers changed it.
“You're an astrophysicist, not some storm
chaser.”
"I'm telling you, there's a connection."
Two years later, that character was the focal
point of a contest hosted by Marvel and the
Science and Entertainment Exchange, where
young women interested in STEM careers could
interview female scientists in the Exchange’s
database for a chance to tour laboratories
and film sets.
“We are very concerned with the way that
scientists are portrayed onscreen.
We want them to be — I mean, you always
want them to be the hero, that’s the best
thing — and a main character is fantastic.
But we want to see women, we want to see people
of color, and we want to see them woven into
the fabric of the everyday life that you see
onscreen.”
Since 1983, repeated studies have shown that
when children are asked to draw a scientist,
they overwhelmingly draw old, white men.
Children usually cite film or cartoon characters
as their main source of inspiration.
In the original research, children drew these
stereotypical characteristics more and more
frequently as they got older.
Science has had another image issue in Hollywood,
too.
A survey of over a thousand horror movies
distributed in Britain between 1931 and 1984
found that scientists and their work were
the villains of 41 percent of films.
Scientists were heroes less than 1 percent
of the time.
In the decades since then, perceptions of
science have gotten better.
An analysis of over 3,000 interviews on public
opinion about scientists found that American
adults in 2001 were much less likely to hold
negative stereotypes about scientists than
they were in 1983.
And they were much more likely to believe
that a science career was a good choice for
their children or for themselves.
“I mean, people do learn from film and television.
Whether you want them to or not.
We often refer to it as an ‘accidental curriculum.’”
One of the most talked-about examples of that
is what’s called the CSI Effect — the
idea that chart-topping crime shows increased
interest in forensic science, but also spread
a lot of misinformation about
the field.
CSI didn't just launch a franchise, it created a false impression when it comes to solving crimes.
Researchers in 2010 found that watching the
show is associated with perceptions of DNA
evidence as much more reliable than it actually
is.
The Exchange wants to mobilize that kind of
effect — and hopefully make science more
understandable and more accessible for everyone.